when you bite into it that's when you're
like oh my god this is really really
good hi i'm shanique and today we're
going to be making pates from the virgin
islands a pate is similar to an empanada
or a jamaican beef patty it's
essentially a pastry that you fill with
beef chicken saltfish whatever you'd
like to fill it with the dough obviously
has to be just right the dough can't be
crispy or flaky it has to be nice and
brown on the outside but when you bite
into it it's doughy i ate it while i was
growing up and i still eat it to this
day when i go back home i'm from st
thomas the culture is fantastic the
music the people the beaches the food as
everyone knows the virgin islands
suffered two major hurricanes last year
virgin islanders are in full-fledged
recovery things have progressed but
there's so much more work to do the idea
around people coming together on social
media and facebook and just really
trying to help as we rebuild it was a
great feeling and showed true solidarity
every time i visit home which is once a
year sometimes even twice a year i
always get a pate and so there's a big
food stand right before you turn into
the airport and they sell lots of
different local foods but what i get
there is the chicken pate the beef pate
my favorite would have to be the beef
pate because i feel with ground beef
you're able to capture the flavors
better when you add the peppers and the
spices that we use it just really brings
out the flavor that much more i remember
in high school my friends and i every
morning would get a pate from a little
shop right across the street from our
high school everybody would go there to
either get johnnycakes or pates saltish
pate beef pate and that was a staple my
daughter has tried pate's pates we were
home not too long ago right after the
hurricane my daughter tried the dough
and she liked it when you first bite
into a pate you usually just get the
crust and the dough but then that second
bite is when you taste the filling the
meat or the chicken or whatever and
that's when you're like oh my god this
is really really good the flavor of the
filling needs to pop in your mouth so
with every bite you want to taste the
spices taste the herbs i really wanted
to try a veggie version i spoke to my
family specifically my brother and my
dad and they were vegetarians and i was
asking them okay okay what kinds of
vegetables do you like in your pate and
they're just like hey the world's your
oyster or carrot essentially and
basically you can use whatever it is you
like so the cool thing about the veggie
pate is that you can just add your
favorite ingredients i would love for
everybody to watch this video and feel
proud if you're from the virgin islands
to feel proud about this dish because
these are the things that make us unique
the idea around showcasing something
that's native to my home and a place
where i grew up and i love it's just
really super
[Music]
delicious oh yes